[Music] in Arizona Sunday when the Eagles face
the Chiefs in Super Bowl 57 they'll leave nothing
on the field in an epic battle that will surely
require some major recovery time after the game
but turns out that is also true for many
of the estimated 100 million Americans
expected to watch the big game on
TV you better believe this team's
the one that can do it and instead of
sore muscles and bruises they may have
other complaints over indulgence in pizza and
wings perhaps or too much beer and booze or
just staying up too late but the result according
to the workforce institute's annual Super Bowl
poll roughly one out of five employed Americans
an estimated 26 million people are likely to miss
at least some work on Monday about 19 million
of those workers the ones who don't work from
home plan to skip work outright or take the
day off nearly 8 million plan to sleep in and
show up late and for the diehards who do manage
to make their way into the workplace on time 33
percent say they will likely be less productive
because of the Super Bowl festivities the night
before according to the folks at Workforce it's an
economically costly problem that's not likely to
improve anytime soon unless of course you happen
to live in Tennessee earlier this week State Rep
Joe towns Jr co-sponsored a bill that would name
the Monday after the Super Bowl and if official
state holiday where did this idea for Super Bowl
Monday come from so it's just kind of like in
general conversation when you're hanging out with
the guys and the gals having a good time on those
days man I wish I didn't have to go to work you
know it's kind of like that in fact that Workforce
poll found around 42 percent of U.S employees
agree believing the day after the Super Bowl
should be a holiday so where is this bill now well
the bill has just been drafted we had our debt
lines last week so it's just been drafted and I'm
working an amendment now so this won't help people
for this year's Super Bowl this would be for the
Super Bowl next year absolutely hey you could
have the Titans in the Super Bowl then next year
now you just spoke it and okay I decree it okay
the Titans will be in the Super Bowl you heard it
here first but as for this year's game so I have
about three places I'll stop by and uh the last
one would be the one that'll cause me to want to
have a day off that was exactly where I was going
are you going to be showing up to work on time on
Monday well I think that with me being initiated
this kind of building everybody ever know that
I would be pulling the leg if I called in sick
okay so I have to be here I will be right at work
I actually feel like he shouldn't be at work
to make the point that you need to have the
bill I mean look this is we were even talking
about I said to him what about let's do this
during the NCAA tournament there's also all the
studies that show all the lack of productivity
during the first week of the NCAA tournament on
Thursday and Friday a lot of people are behind
this in Cincinnati last year the schools I think
delayed the start times so the kids could watch
so look people would like to watch their game
and enjoy it and you've got to recover I saw I
heard one stat this week that some people you
know when they make a lot of food eat up to 11
000 calories on Super Bowl Sunday that means
a lot of sleep time after treatment yeah I
guess or go to the gym maybe I guess so
there you go I shouldn't go on the diet
later on so maybe not maybe not today or
tomorrow Tuesday after the Super Bowl okay